coffee shops wouldn't serve me pubs
banned me
restaurants wouldn't allow me and that's
how far it went
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
an interesting guest we have for you
today it's mr brexit himself nigel
farage welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much pleasure to be here
in brexit britain
[Laughter]
you you started off very nonpartisan
there nigel well done
uh but listen it's great to have you on
i i just set
the table a little bit and get our cards
on that table
francis and i both voted romaine there
will be a lot of people who watch the
show
who who who love you there'll be lots of
people who watch the show who who hate
you there'll be lots of people who watch
the show who are
sort of in the middle between those two
but i think for us the way we feel about
it if someone is objective about your
career they would have to admit
that in terms of achieving your results
now people may hate the results you've
achieved but
you've been one of the most successful
politicians in my lifetime certainly
um now i wanted to talk a little bit
about where that comes from because
you've had to fight you know when you're
standing there next to the candidate
for the monster raving looney party and
you're closer to him
than you are to to winning that election
all those years ago
what is it that makes you tick and keep
fighting and keep going
well i think once i was quite normal um
because i
i you know i left school i skipped
university because the
the boom in the city had started you
know thatcher had been elected
uh there was the the development of
something called the yuppie
and i thought yeah look at that i want
to be a yuppie so i skipped university
went to work in the city of london
worked on a place called london metal
exchange
um which as i've always said to people
we used to work very hard up until
lunchtime every day
to disintegrate pretty quickly um and i
played golf you know i was a four
handicap golfer
i got married young had kids young
and i was all set really you know
to to stay in the commodity business and
the real ambition was to make money
and live as high lifestyle as i possibly
could
politics current affairs what i'd always
cared about those things
passionately you know i mean growing up
through the 1970s
seeing the three-day week doing homework
by candlelight because of the power
strikes uh
seeing inflation get to nearly 30
percent
then seeing this woman mrs thatcher
appear
as if from nowhere become prime minister
with a radical
new agenda so i'd always cared about
politics and current affairs and the
funny thing was
working in commodities you know very
much a global business copper aluminium
all these things
you know politics and current affairs
affected those prices politics and
current affairs
well what we talked about all day long
and i was
an avid free market here um you know a
great believer
in reaganomics um in much of what
thatcher
stood for i mean i could see the
downside of it but i thought we have to
have
these radical reforms we have to take
this medicine
so i always cared about all of these
issues hugely
followed you know what happened in
parliament very closely
but i'd never had the slightest
intention
even to stand for the local council
i thought no no that's not for me you
know politics is for the oxbridge set
you know i'll let them get on with that
i'll get on with what i do
but what dawned on me in
1990 and we did a day on the exchange
it was 5 5 30 in the evening we were
you guessed it in the pub in the city
and this of course is before almost
anybody had a mobile phone
um and you know one of the young lads
ran into the bar from the office into
the pub from the office and said
we've just joined the exchange rate
mechanism now that was
the means by which we pegged sterling
against a basket of european currencies
mainly across the deutsche mark
and that was a precursor to us joining
what we now know as the euro now i won't
um on trigonometry uh you tell you the
anglo-saxon words that i used on hearing
this news
but i simply couldn't believe it and the
next day going to london by train
the conservative party supported erm the
labour party supported erm the liberals
supported
erm the tuc supported erm the cbi
supported erm and pretty much every
single national newspaper
supported erm and i looked at this and i
thought this
is going to be a disaster we are at a
completely different
phase of the economic cycle to germany
and central european economies
we are very much a services economy
they're much more
a manufacturing economy um i could see
that the 80s boom had come to an end
and that you know negative equity was
appearing in property prices i could see
that a bust
was coming uh and i just thought this is
going to be a disaster well
for the next two years i bored the life
out of
anybody that would listen you know in
the office
on the train coming home from london i
mean wherever i
i became an erm board and of course it's
all born out
because the madness of what happened in
september 92
when interest rates doubled just to keep
the pound up
and still inside the exchange rate
mechanism and that year
was the year of record home
repossessions
that year was the record year for small
business bankruptcies and i thought to
myself
i don't know what it is but i could see
something
that the political class couldn't see
and i realized that establishment status
quos
form around a set of ideas and this is
true not just a politics it's true in
science it's true in business
a status quo forms around an idea
and and groupthink takes over or lack of
proper thinking
takes over so i'd seen that experience
i've been right about
it and then you know hard on the heels
of that we had this thing called the
maastricht treaty
which is when the european community
became the european union
and i watched the tory rebels in
parliament
you know do their best fight a rearguard
action but in the end
john major put it down to a motion of
confidence
and of course like good little boys they
all went and supported the party
and voted for the very thing that they'd
said would be an economic
and political disaster for our nation
and its independence i thought this is
really odd
because in my village people don't
support this
in my village people want to be friendly
with europe and trade with europe and
not be governed by
and i just determined then in 93 i said
you know what
i don't care i really don't care
even if i'm the only person that votes
for me
as a matter of principle i'm going to
fight these so-and-so's
so i put myself up for a by-election
i did beat screaming lord such only by
100
148 votes i beat david such by a hundred
people what a lovely bloke he was um and
all my friends and family said but
surely
this experience must put you off you
know it's impossible
to take on the establishment and i i
suppose then what kicked in
was an absolute belief that i was right
and just sheer bloody mindedness
and so i never stopped and i kept
campaigning in 1994 95 96 97
i never stopped campaigning i never
stopped you know
going out speaking in village halls and
if i got an audience of 30 or 40 i'd be
thrilled
in those days and i kept on battling
away
and then the big opportunity came for me
and that was in 1999 when for the first
time in the history of this country
a national election was contested on the
basis of proportional
representation and so i got elected to
the european parliament in 1999
and as a result of that you know you
start to get invited onto question time
and these programs although i mean
i mean i was treated you know i mean by
the dimblebys and all these people as if
i was on sort of
day release from a lunatic asylum you
know
but so so really that's the story the
story is
the consensus establishment had decided
this was our future for the for the next
foreseeable
uh decades or forever um and i just felt
they were wrong
i was right and i always in the bottom
of my heart felt
that actually middle england didn't
agree with any of this so it's
it's it's nice of you to say that i've
been very successful
in achieving my goals and i have i just
wish you hadn't taken 27 years
well i was going to ask you on a
personal level you you talk about the
political conviction which i think
everybody would recognize but
is there a part of you just likes
pissing people off nigel just a little
bit
just annoying winding people up a little
bit is there a part of you that's that
as well
oh enormously
i mean i we were taught
i was very lucky i really was lucky to
go to a good school
and and to be taught by some great
people and
you know the older guys that taught me
who were all you know they'd all
driven tanks or flown spitfires or
whatever it was or they played cricket
for england what an amazing group of
people we had
at dallas teaching us and you know the
good ones taught
us question everything don't accept
anything at face value
question everything debate everything i
don't think you know during my teens i
sort of took that to the nth degree
often of articulating positions that i
didn't believe in at all uh just because
i enjoyed
uh getting the reaction back although
nothing could prepare me i suppose
for becoming the pantomime villain of
the european parliament i mean you know
amazing you know when i
got up to speak and sort of 500 people
started booing
now most human beings would not want to
live with that experience
most human beings would temper their
ideas because
normally people like to fit in normally
people like to feel
a sense of belonging but it just didn't
it just didn't matter to me um and in
the
in the latter years i mean in brussels
particularly
you know coffee shops wouldn't serve me
pubs banned me
restaurants wouldn't allow me and i mean
that's how far it went
and yeah and yet i took it all as a
compliment i thought
i remember in 2014 and that was the
worst of it 2014 was the worst of it in
terms of the press and it was just
unbelievable i mean for standing up and
saying that i thought the foreign aid
budget was being badly spent
for standing up and saying that i
thought actually
the untrammeled free movement of
unskilled labor was really not helping
working people in britain
pushing down their wages damaging their
access to public services i mean
i look back the other day some of the
interviews i was doing with sky news and
the bbc back in 2014
i mean you really would have thought for
all the world
that i was heralding you know 1930s
german style fascism
to come into britain and that was the
level of hostility
to my ideas and they've now become
mainstream ideas
anyway it was difficult and i remember
one morning
on sunday morning in 2014 the phone rang
here at about 7 a.m
and it was my lawyer the oh my god the
law is reading on a sunday boy but this
can't be good
and he just said to me andrew he said
you know what
don't buy the newspapers don't have a
look online
just don't read any of it
because it will damage your confidence
and i took his advice
and as the years went on i just didn't
read any of it
i certainly didn't look at twitter and
see what people were saying
i stuck to what i believed in what i
knew to be true
i did my absolute best to be honest with
people
about what i thought brexit meant and
what some of the downsides might be i
did that all through
the referendum campaign as well but it
was tough to withstand it but i
i never forget in 14 getting a letter
written in spidery handwriting and the
man said dennis farage i'm 93 years old
during the war i served in bomber
command he said i can tell you
you only start taking heavy flak when
you're getting
near the target and i never ever forgot
that letter
the establishment were literally
terrified of me
brussels perhaps even more so um and so
i
i learned um i learned to um
enjoy my own company
because nobody else wanted to be seen or
taught you and even
you know you go to the supermarket you
know going around
you know the local waitrose buying the
essentials you know gin tonic lemons
that sort of thing
and you know and people would look like
good luck with it all so i hope the
neighbors haven't seen i spoke to him
it was as if this sort of mantle of
being the devil was put upon me so
so there must have been something
slightly unusual in my makeup
um to make me endure it and you know if
i'm being honest i can laugh about it
now
some of it was pretty tough and nigel we
talk about you know
something you know experiences being
very tough you've had
a lot of epithets being held against you
far right racist etc etc
in your own opinion why do you think it
is that people have hold these epithets
at you
oh i think that i think that when you
challenge orthodoxy
rather than examining
whether the criticism of the orthodoxy
is valid or not
uh you seek to dismiss the other person
with abuse and insults it was the great
uh
gandhi wasn't it who said about the
campaign for indian
independence from the british empire you
know first
they ignore you then they laugh at you
then they attack you and then you win a
complete refusal
to deal with ideas and a belief that
just by hurling abuse
you can destroy the other side um and
and
i mean cameron tried it was quite funny
actually cameron tried it
uh cameron was on with nick ferrari on
rbc
he was asked about nigel farage and ukip
oh he said a bunch of fruitcakes loonies
and closet racists mostly
now that was quite a wounding thing
for a prime minister to say about a
party that i led
but actually it helped us because people
could see how unreasonable
he was being you know everyone said oh
farrah stands for this farage stands for
that well
have you ever ever actually read what
he's actually said
and it was as if people were choosing to
interpret what i'd said
rather than actually reading the words
and and and you know truth of it is
that nation states make their own laws
nation-states have their own courts
nation states control their own borders
and choose who they think are fit and
proper people to come and settle in
their country i mean these were all
perfectly reasonable
at the sensible points of view but were
demonized because they challenged
the establishment and i you know i would
say this
uh to anybody uh that tries to
you know paint out ukip and and what it
stood for
in in that racist way you know i was the
only party leader
who banned anybody who'd ever been a
member of the british national party
from even becoming a member of uk you
know i drew that line
within my own party and you know
something
in 2006 nick griffin had quite a big
tailwind behind him
you know a lot of dispossessed white
working class who were very unhappy
what was happening in their communities
had started to vote for nick griffin
once i drawn that line that we wouldn't
accept
bnp members and supporters but if you
were
holding your nose and voting bmp as a
protest but didn't agree
with their outright racist policies you
could come and vote for me
and they did i think i did more i mean
here we are
here's the funny thing about my critics
i i honestly believe
i did more to stop the rise of the far
right in this country than
any other individual and i really mean
that
and nigel do you know do you ever look
back on the campaign with ukip
and also with brexit and go i made a
misstep here i gave
ammunition to the people criticizing me
do you know something on those days
you know during election campaigns on
those days out in the road
um on the road you know i go to a market
town in staffordshire right for
argument's sake
you know i do a street walk about go in
the betting shop
go in the pub you know meet people in
the town square
and i would then probably spend the next
three to four
hours being interviewed by local
newspapers
local radio stations you know local
broadcasters on
you know youtube or whatever else it
would be i mean i i gave more interviews
than anybody ever because i had to do
that to propel this party
into the public's consciousness you
cannot you cannot
do thousands of hours of interviews you
cannot
speak you know hundreds of thousands of
words without sometimes making a mistake
of course
we're all human we're all bound to make
mistakes
we're all bound to say things that we
think afterwards oh well that wasn't
very bright
because i know how they're gonna portray
it so of course we make mistakes but
but what i would say
or what i do think came through to
people
whether they agreed with what i was
saying or not
i like to think that i put the message
across in a very clear
succinct way so that people under that
understand what the message is
and i think i managed to get that
through and i also think
that people felt again whether they
agreed or not
that what i was saying i genuinely and
sincerely believed it
yeah and the other thing i think people
felt and this included people like me
who weren't
at the time on a completely different
side of the argument
uh was that you were being subject to
different standards than everybody else
you were being unfairly treated by
large sections of the media and you know
frankly maybe if they if they'd not done
that you might not have been as
successful do you think that's possible
if they just
let you on the shows and didn't treat
you as this sort of weirdo you know it's
very interesting
i was talking yesterday talked to a
political commentator who made the point
to me
that in the 2015 general election when
ukip got four million votes in one seat
you know ukip got more votes
than the snp and the lib dems and plied
all added up together
and one seat almost that sense of
injustice
what had happened within our system i
think propelled even more people to vote
leave
in the referendum of 2016 that would
have done before so yes i think there
are a lot of very fair-minded people out
there
who don't like bullying who don't like
unfairness and ironically
i think you're right i think the worse
they behave the more unreasonable
they were i think in many ways the more
it galvanized support behind me yes
francis how is your cyber security i've
got a virus from an unnamed website of
course you do
you're not alone francis during the
pandemic british
online infrastructure has faced an
astronomical rise
in targeted cyber attacks which is what
i'm sure happened to you
that is dreadful what can i do to defend
myself
that is where pockets seem come in they
offer businesses like ours
a special solution that alerts us to
hackers crackers
and malicious employees like anton not
only that
they are the only scene provided to
offer pay
as you go cyber defense for companies
they're british based
absolutely and they're from doncaster so
they need the work
i mean you say that actually they have
kept their prices flat during the
pandemic to make sure companies can get
the protection they need
pocket seem are offering trigonometry
fans a 10
discount all you got to do is hit them
up by email at
info pocketseem.co.uk and
make sure the subject of that email is
trigonometry
and they will give you your 10 discount
for managed cyber security
that email again is i n f o
p o c k e t s
i e m dot co dot uk
and don't forget to have trigonometry in
your subject line
so you get your 10 discount can i just
say if you need
that spell you really shouldn't be
running a business
nigel to my mind you were one of the
first mainstream political figures
when i became politically aware that was
talking about immigration
why is it that immigration is such a
taboo subject in this country
and if you come out in favor of limiting
immigration that immediately paid she
was being
far right and all the rest of it
yeah yeah well i think i've long
believed
that the greatest intellectual
that we had in post-war politics in
britain was he not pal i mean
i mean hard to disagree with that i mean
the man was extraordinary
the man was brilliant the man was very
far excited and if i
look at what he was saying about the
common market in 1972 it's all come true
but but the speech that he gave in 1968
the speech that became known as the
rivers of speech
i think it was so ill-judged
in terms of its tone and the way that it
was allowed to be interpreted
that it almost put the tin lid on having
a sensible immigration debate
for decades after that and i think that
did real
real damage when i was first elected
in 1999 on all of my
election literature the word immigration
didn't appear didn't appear
why because net migration into britain
was averaging about 30 000 a year
it was still at a level that concerned
some people but it was
let's be honest about it it was pretty
manageable and i looked at things in the
late 90s
and i compared assimilation integration
of different communities in the united
kingdom and compare it to france and
germany
or the netherlands or anywhere else in
europe you know we've done this better
than anybody else
we really had done this better than
anybody else
so i didn't even discuss immigration and
the same applied in two 2000 2001 2002
when i saw when i saw
that what blair had done was to open the
doors
effectively to the world but then
especially
to open the doors to eight and then ten
former communist countries
some of whom had minimum wages that were
seven eight times lower
than the british minimum wage some of
which had not made the transition
from being communist states to free
western economies
and when mr blair told us that 13 000
people a year would arrive as a result
of this
i thought this is the moment this is
gonna become the issue so
i made a very big call in 2004
a very big call i said that millions
would come
i said huge numbers would come to
britain i said it would have a very
damaging effect on you know the life of
lots of ordinary people
and so that was the moment that was the
moment that immigration became part of
my
political fight why does it matter so
much well of course
it doesn't matter if you're a cabinet
minister
it doesn't matter if you're rich it
doesn't matter
if you're a big business owner because
it means cheaper nannies
cheaper gardeners and cheap labor
but it matters hugely to everybody else
because we did unquestionably see
compression of labor crises
with our primary schools just not simply
began to cope
with the numbers um and and
you know disjointed communities where
you know
the numbers coming in that spoke foreign
languages or from different cultures
were so fast that we weren't getting
that level
of integration that we need to have a
settled happy society so
without immigration without with two
things actually without immigration and
without the internet
the uk would have remained a fringe
force
in british politics but those two things
propelled it
to where it got to and nigel all three
of us i'm
i came to this country in 1995 from a
former soviet country
uh in russia and i remember actually the
point that you make the levels were so
low
no one really cared about immigration i
think the public concern about
immigration at the time was about three
percent
in 1995. it changed when you got it it
changed when i got here
absolutely i i single-handedly ruined it
um
but but you understand coming from your
background you understand what i mean
i mean countries like bulgaria
and romania which is so much in the grip
of organized crime
you know we the sensible thing to do
would have been to be cautious but we
weren't
and and of course i was called all sorts
of things for daring to say this
at this but that was how ordinary folk
felt and and you know yourself having
come here in 1995
that you know you would not find a
country
in the european time zone more welcoming
and more open
than this in the world nigel in the
world i make this point to people all
the time
all the time britain is one of the most
tolerant welcoming places in the entire
history of the human race
and that really was what shifted my
thoughts on a lot of this stuff because
i saw after the referendum in which i
was a very strong remain supporter
at the time suddenly the explanation for
why brexit happened was that everybody
in this country was racist and that's
when i went no
that isn't true that's not my experience
as a dark-skinned immigrant in this
country
yeah that was disgusting i mean let's be
honest about it
you know talking to you guys your
remainers but you're democrats you
accept the result that's great
of course you know that's how it should
be but
frankly the behavior of large sections
of our elected politicians in
westminster
to completely refuse to accept the
result
of the of the referendum to denigrate
as you've just pointed out those who
dared to vote against the establishment
view
and then every attempt to prevent it
from happening
or make us vote again i honestly think
that in a hundred years time
we will look back at the history of this
period and school kids will be taught
it's one of the most shameful episodes
in what is supposed to be a democratic
country
so did you get what you wanted nigel
because we've got
brexit uh we got the australian style
point system that you were talking about
right that's we've got a tory government
uh
but the numbers of people coming into
the country are the same as they ever
were
oh yes i mean look you know the
conservative party are not a
conservative party i mean
it's this complete misnomer um and
and boris johnson and the sort of posh
boys around him
um they don't regard immigration as an
issue they used it briefly in the
referendum very briefly
in the referendum because it suited
their purposes to do so
um and you're right uh net migration is
still running at very very high levels
and we also face a very big dilemma
as to what to do about hong kong and i
say big dilemma
because you know i am
very concerned about the influence the
chinese communist party is having upon
the free world
upon his own world too and yet
you know what would it mean if 300 000
or 3 million people came and settled in
the united kingdom
from hong kong so so
i think that is the time when the
immigration debate will be back on
um for the moment
for the moment uh the conservatives are
able
to get away with something which is the
public perception
is that because of brexit we've dealt
with the issue the truth is we haven't
the truth is we haven't and look you
know you ask me that question i mean the
truth is
that you never ever
get everything you want in victory
sometimes losing's easier
it's a bit like trading the markets you
know you've got a position on the
markets
it's going wrong you can't sleep for a
week
you get rid of the position you take
your loss you feel almost a sense of
relief
that it's over when you've got a winning
trade
you always say oh i should have done it
in a bigger size
i should have got out a bit earlier
victory is never perfect
but look when i see what's happened
with our withdrawal from the european
medicines agency
and the fact that we've been able to act
in the interests of our own people
with the vaccine roll out compared to
the absolute
shambles in brussels uh
that i think that i think will be the
lasting testament
as to why being in control
of national decisions and having those
decisions made by people
directly accountable to us is a better
way of doing things so
look i'm not happy about the fishing
deal i'm very unhappy about northern
ireland being cast out
and there are some ridiculous things
going on um you know with goods at our
borders but
overall overall
we're in a good place and you know it's
interesting isn't it just a few days ago
we've learned that the 25 tariff on
scotch whiskey
something that really hurts you know
scotland's got enough economic problems
without that industry with nearly 50 000
people working in
and around scotch whiskey that because
we've left the european union
we've been able to negotiate that tariff
being suspended
so i think there are lots of arguments
and lots of reasons that will say to us
as the years go by that brexit was the
right thing to do
and i think those debates and those
questions will now be asked in european
capitals
as well and what do you think is going
to be the future nigel of the european
union do you think that
they were going to go on and become this
cur federation of european states which
is
what they want or do you think that the
kibosh has been placed on it because of
the pandemic
and the fact that a lot of these
countries have their own uh
brexit or whatever it may be movement to
leave
well they've already gone a long way i
mean you know think about it you know
why is the speed limit for lorries on
our roads 56 miles an hour
because it's a because it's 80
kilometers you know that was set in
brussels
you know why is it that our swipe cards
are going up in value
because we've left the european union
we're now free to choose our own limits
i mean the extent to which already
the eu governs people's lives is pretty
extraordinary i
i've always taken the view that
the greatness of europe as a continent
is the incredible linguistic and
cultural diversity that exists within it
you know drive a thousand miles across
the midwest of america
i mean every gas station is the same you
know everything's the same
uh you drive a hundred miles across
europe you meet completely different
people
eating different types of cheese i mean
that's the beauty of europe is that it
is so diverse
and provided that it's democratic
it'll be a peaceful europe too and i
think
i think in many ways post 1945
i mean don't forget we weren't occupied
were we we didn't live through
what many of the what many of these
people lived through in two world wars
occupation massacre of tens of millions
of people
and the conclusion that was drawn
was that the existence of nation states
had led to these terrible wars
so what we have to do is to abolish
nation states
but at no point to tell the public
that's what the plan is i mean that's
where the eu started
and it's not the existence of nation
states that causes war in fact you're
actually more likely
to have wars if you have if you have a
remote
you know bureaucracy that you can't vote
for and can't remove
provided nation state to democratic you
will have peace
i can't think of a single example of two
mature functioning democracies going to
war with each other and that is
something
i think we should be thinking about very
very hard when it comes to the future of
europe
nigel and moving on now talking about
mature functioning democracies one of
the things that i think we'll probably
disagree most on is your mate donald
trump
now i don't know no one here on the show
has this sort of
instinctive aversion to him where he's
the devil incarnate and whatever but
i have to say and there's plenty of
people who who are fans of trump who
watch our show and we have the same
respect for them as we do for the rest
of our audience but
were you not troubled nigel you just
talked about how the the establishment
in this country refused to accept the
results of the referendum
were you not troubled by donald trump's
rhetoric about the fake news election
uh the election was stolen it was all
the fraud
resulting in people being in washington
resulting in
people storming the capital poor woman
got shot over it
for really nothing they were never going
to change anything did you not regret
in any way your support for him in that
moment
so let's talk about double standards
shall we yeah
let's let's talk about double standards
beginning on november the 8th
2016 and for the next
four years the democrats
cnn and the new york times did
everything they could
to delegitimize trump's election victory
i agree with you completely i agree with
you i agree endless
let me just pause you there just for for
one reason which is we've covered all of
that on the show
a lot we've talked about blm and antifa
violence
a lot this is all things on which we can
agree actually
but trump what he did after the last
election
do you not think that was also
responsible
look i said
in mid-august right in mid-august
i was on steve bannon's show in
washington
he said what's going to happen with the
election i said well before the virus i
thought trump would win by a landslide
i said but now what i can see for the
first time in american history
is the mass transfer to postal voting to
absentee
postal voting i said i tell you what i
think will happen
trump will win on the day comfortably
but lose
as we get the camp back over the next
few days
i have witnessed at firsthand
how the postal voting system is wide
open
to fraud and abuse in this country i've
seen it
i've complained about it for 20 years it
is not
a safe system it's why france
effectively has just stopped it
completely was trump right
to question the integrity of postal
ballots
yes was he right
to point out that somehow
the republican party had won seats
across the state legends had won seats
in the house of representatives and that
somehow
this mass vote for biden in the big
cities
looked anonymous yes of course he was
quite right
to do it was it
given the febrile atmosphere that was
that was
around was it wise to do a rally
on the 6th of january in washington dc
no
i don't think it was but i
again i mean the way that that speech he
gave that day was twisted and
manipulated but the media was quite
something you know
he said to them go in peace some of them
chose not
to um so look i yeah i do think the
sixth of
january rally was a mistake just given
how febrile it was
uh but i think he is in in many ways uh
the most misquoted
the most misinterpreted political figure
that i've ever seen and i tell you what
right now if you live in london right
now
you are getting letters almost bullying
you
to go onto a postal vote register and
this i think this
election integrity is going to become a
massive issue
in both british and american politics
but but do you not think nigel that
some of donald trump's rhetoric was
inflammatory
and as a result that royal people up and
in a way you could argue that type of
backlash was inevitable
after you spent months questioning the
veracity of the election
i think if you look at his words if you
look at his words on the day they
weren't
however however i think rudy giuliani's
words were very questionable
yeah very questionable indeed the thing
that troubled me about it as well nigel
i you know we've had plenty of pro-trump
guests on the show and we give everybody
a
fair hearing as we've given you but yeah
with trump when that happened i started
to get a sort of
cult of personality vibe of the whole
thing
how some people were reacting people
were claiming that it was actually blm
infiltrators who'd stormed
all of this sort of crazy stuff and you
that's when i went hold on a second
these really
these people some of these people really
believe all this crazy nonsense
and that troubled me did that trouble
you
yeah i never bought into any of that and
you wouldn't expect me to
no of course you know i said i said two
days after the election i
said however hard the trump team try
to overturn this result they will not
succeed
knowing the abuses that take place for
postal voting and proving them
are two different things you're talking
to somebody that lost a court case in
2019
over postal voting in peterborough and
so i always thought
i always thought that he would lose and
it wouldn't be possible
to prove it look you say cult of
personality
he has he's brought together the
republican party in a way
that no other human being could have
done he's broadened the appeal
of the republican party in a way that no
other
no other leader has been able to do and
you know you look at the rising share of
black and hispanic voters now turning up
voting for trump
and the republican party you look at the
class base
there are many more working-class people
voting republican
than they did before now i know that i
know that in the middle class suburbs
they find them a bit a little bit rich
for their
for their time but whichever way you cut
this
you know i've seen it i've seen it on
the ground this guy has a level of
personal support that is phenomenal
and we're now moving into a new phase
and this is i think this is interesting
guys
so when hillary lost in 2016 the
democrats effectively did not have a
leader for the next few
years you know schumer and pelosi would
speak
for the democrats
cnn and the new york times effectively
became the opposition
what you've now got is a leader
of the republican party in place as an
opposition leader um and i think
you know you saw his opening speech at
cpac and i think he's going to prove to
be a very
very effective opposition leader i
really do
do you think he's going to run again in
2024 do you know something every us
president that goes into the white house
when they leave after four years or
eight years they've aged about 30 years
trump looks fitter and more energized
you know now that he did in 2016
when he went there um
he i mean he will face a choice when he
he will certainly lead the party up to
the midterms in 2022.
all right i'm i'm absolutely certain of
that he will then have to decide whether
he wants to do it again
or whether he wants to become the king
maker um
my my sense of him
and who he is and the i love him or hate
him
the phenomenal drive i mean this this
guy is just amazing
i mean you know i know a lot of people
that work for him i mean none of them
could even keep up with it
but he's just extraordinary my sense is
that he intends to run again yeah
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now
all you've got to do is head over to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
and use our promo code which is of
course triggered as well
and you will get 50 percent off with the
initial purchase
sign up for the newsletter access of
easy
that tells you everything you need to
know about technology
privacy and censorship and nigel
we've seen trump lose the election we've
seen brexit come to fruition
this has been all uh under the umbrella
of right-wing populism i don't know if
you agree with it or if you disagree
with it but do you think that particular
movement that you and trump work the
helm of has now
run its course and we're now going to
see a different political movement take
the helm
no i don't at all actually i i mean it's
called right-wing populism but actually
a lot of the policies aren't right-wing
at all
and a lot of the supporters i mean look
at this country who were the people
voting
who were the people turning up for you
given the brexit party lots of them
old labour voters you know
i was like the gateway drug for boris
johnson wasn't i you know
once they'd broken that link with the
labour party they were okay to move on
and vote touring in 2019. no i think
that the
one of the lessons um of the great
shocks
with the brexit vote and with the trump
vote
is that is that the liberal
establishment learned nothing from it at
all
they are intent on continuing to pursue
the same course
they've added to it a new level of
walkery
that leads so many people just shaking
their heads
i'm wondering what's going on so no
far from it i think i think this
movement
that says the capital cities are out of
touch
with flyover states or middle england or
whatever the equivalent
in the end's going to be in italy or
france or germany
no no no i i i i think trump losing
was kind of a hiccup um along that path
i think politics
western politics has fundamentally
changed and i really believe it'll go on
doing so
and moving on now to china which you i
think you would say
is the next big issue of our time could
you explain
why you believe that and what are the
challenges we're going to face with a
chat with uh
china in particular led by the ccp
well i mean if we you know if we talked
about a country
that imprisons hundreds of thousands
of one of its minorities in re-education
camps um that actually enforces
sterilization of rather large numbers of
women i mean
that alone if we were to raise as an
issue
for somebody that might be a great
trading partner and friend of ours going
forwards
you know the red light would go up
immediately but it doesn't
we have the the handover deal
with hong kong where their autonomy was
supposed to be guaranteed to 2047
and where democracy is literally being
snuffed out with every week that goes by
and yet
we say very little
we have the origin of this virus
that has done the world so much harm and
yet no one dares
really criticize the extent of the
cover-ups
that clearly took place in wuhan
why is it that china is
able to buy up mineral resources to gain
influence in our country to be allowed
to be part of the 5g network at least
initially
why is this all happening and this is my
take on it all right
they have very qui very cleverly
subverted many
of the ruling classes of our country and
i'm talking about
senior civil servants senior political
figures
big businessmen and women you know just
look at the
just look at the advisory board of
huawei over the last five years
it's a roll call of all of those people
and you know the prime minister
i mean he has a father that has a very
good relationship with beijing and
with the former ambassador in london a
brother
that you know has worked for goldman
sachs in beijing
now works for them in hong kong and when
he's asked about the arrest of the
democracy activist says we must
understand this is china now
he's got another brother that when he
was university's minister
twinned reading university with
one of the technology colleges in china
i mean
is it any surprise that boris declares
himself to be a sino fight
because all the influences around him
are pro
china which is led by the ccp so i just
think
that the more we talk about this issue
the more appalled people will be i mean
for example
if i order on amazon right
it does not tell me when i'm buying a
product where it's made
so it's quite difficult for me even not
to buy goods from china
even if i want to and you know the belt
and road
strategy that's been outlined very
clearly
by president xi you know that is an
attempt
to basically to take over the world and
it's happening
without much comment and i think that
poses a great threat to us i really do
i find it interesting as someone who
comes from the soviet union you know
some of the stuff that the chinese are
doing now to some of their citizens are
what happened in my country
but at that time people didn't really
know it was happening until soldier
nitin came out and wrote the gulag
archipelago and word finally got out
but now we know and we still seemingly
don't care
is it just the economics nigel we're so
tied in
the that that frankly the ordinary
consumer in the west
yes we sort of care about the uyghurs
but but we want the cheap iphone
well actually some of the polling on
this is very interesting you know some
of the polling
is beginning to show a shift where
consumers are beginning to say they are
prepared to pay a bit more
not to buy goods from china but it's
quite difficult to avoid them
in many areas particularly if if the
origin of manufacture is hidden
as it is with so many online sales there
is a shift
going on um but it's not been more rapid
because very few people in high command
in our country are prepared to say so
and and not in every case but in many
cases
the self-same people that were happy to
sell us out to brussels
are happy to sell us out to beijing
nigel well before we move on towards the
end of the interview and ask
a typical last question i was just
what do you make of boris johnson
well look you know he's a he's a jolly
fellow
he's quite good at spreading around a
bit of optimism
you make him sound like a dog nigel
[Laughter]
tears you up sits on your lap new
wallpaper that's causing all the trouble
um i i mean i
i have honestly got
no idea what he stands for none
absolutely no idea what he stands for he
certainly isn't conservative
in any way he pretends to be an election
time
but he's sort of a metro liberal really
isn't he yeah and that's
kind of where the conservative party has
gone
um it was exactly that
under cameron and osborne
and i almost think when you look at the
sort of coterie of people
i mean cummings was an exception but but
perhaps but when you look at the coterie
of people
um you know around boris you know we
kind of are back to
the oxbridge posh set running the
country and i think they're really very
very disconnected but
hey they said they'd get brexit done
it's imperfect but they have they've got
everything wrong with the pandemic
everything wrong
and yet the vaccine is saving them um
but boris is boris's greatest attribute
and it's really back to it's really back
to napoleon not wanting good generals
but wanting lucky generals is that
first boris johnson had to face jeremy
corbyn
and now he's got some bloke called
stammer
most of the electorate couldn't pick out
of a lineup
so there is so there is no real
effective opposition
so i suspect i suspect that he'll be
prime minister
as long as he wants to be and nigel does
that mean we're in political crisis then
if we've got no effect of opposition
um i think politics is permanently in
crisis in many ways
yeah i mean look the labour party needs
to decide what it is
uh and and you can see that starmar
tries to ride
both horses at once they've got to work
out what they actually are
um you could argue
you could argue that far from being in
crisis
we're in a period of relative stability
you know we had crisis didn't we
perpetual crisis really
from 2016 to the end of 2019 it went on
and on and on and on and on
we're now in a period of stability that
doesn't mean we'll get good government
it doesn't mean we'll get good screws in
it but the odd thing
is that large sections of the electorate
just don't care anymore
they've lived through the emotional
trauma of brexit
and frankly what do they want to do they
want to get out of lockdown
get into the sunshine and enjoy their
lives politics has slipped
way down people's agendas from where it
was so we are in for a period of
relatively quiet politics
well it's possibly no bad thing to be
honest with you given how heated it has
got
uh but nigel thank you for coming on the
show we've got one final question for
you which is
always the same which is what is the one
thing that we're not talking about
as a society that we really should be
the indoctrination in our schools
uh and it's not just in universities
it's not just
at secondary level actually from the
ages of seven
or eight there are all sorts of very
pernicious ideas being fed
into the minds of young children about
this country
their identity and i think we need to
have a good
honest open debate about it because i'm
very disturbed by some of it
well let's let's talk about that a
little bit francis and i will have a lot
to say and a lot of questions to ask you
that's an issue we cover
a lot and what you're really referring
to is the culture war
the the battle over gender identity the
battle over our history the battle over
uh the heritage the way we should think
about britain and the rest of the west
is
on in a sort of balanced way or do we
only focus on the negatives
why do you think that is such an
important issue
because i think we're poisoning the
minds of our young children uh
i i think we're we're not just poisoning
them
but we're also as a direct result of all
of this
dividing everybody up you know
martin luther king who i think we all
admire
not just for his oratory which was my
goodness be extraordinary
but for his message you know i want my
four children to be judged
not with the color of their skin but for
the content of their character
and now we're saying ah you're black
you're in that group
you're asian you're in that group you're
transgender you're in that group
we're dividing everybody up we're not
bringing people together
and to to try and tell white people
that somehow they are guilty and on some
of the wilder fringes
of academia but somehow the united
kingdom
great britain i mean you know we're as
bad as nazi germany
according to some of these people this
is marxist
poison that is being fed into the minds
of young people
and of course it you know its goal is to
bring down the state entirely to bring
down capitalism completely
and yet it's not being opposed because
we don't have people
in politics robust enough to stand up to
this stuff and you know you've seen it
you've covered it
you know i mean when's it i mean it goes
beyond schools for goodness sake when
senior police officers take the knee
to an organization that wants to defund
them i think we've got a bit of a
problem so yeah
i do the whole culture war stuff uh
i i think it is desperately important
that we fight this and if we don't
we'll finish up with a society bitterly
divided
and with more emily we've ever seen
before
and on that upbeat note thank you very
much
nigel for coming on the show um if
people
want to follow you where's the best
place to do you have a youtube channel
now as well don't you yeah
they can get me on youtube they can get
me whatever they like i'm everywhere
twitter youtube facebook
websites google me i'm there okay nigel
thank you very much for coming on it's
been a great pleasure chatting with you
and thank you all for watching we will
see you very soon with another episode
uh or a live stream all of them at 7 pm
uk time take care
see you soon guys we hope you've enjoyed
this incredible interview
remember to subscribe and hit the bell
button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below